bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée au coulisses de la
mondialisation après la claque
australienne la France à l'offensive
dans l'Indo-Pacifique Olivier bèche
ministre délégué au Commerce extérieur
revient d'une tournée dans la région il
est mon invité bonjour Olivier bèche
bonjour alors c'était quoi vos objectifs
de cette tournée Australie Singapour
Indonésie écoutez il y en avait
plusieurs d'abord le premier c'était
évidemment après la visite du Premier
ministre australien en France où il a pu
avec Emmanuel Macron
réécrire une nouvelle page de cette
relation entre la France et l'Australie
premier objectif c'était effectivement
d'être le premier ministre français qui
a revenir en Australie après la fameuse
crise des sous-marins voilà donc c'était
pour essayer de donner un peu de contenu
à cette nouvelle relation cette nouvelle
page que nous allons écrire avec
l'Australie dire voilà la page des
sous-marins elle est tournée nous avons
beaucoup à faire ensemble donc ça
c'était vraiment le premier objectif et
je dois dire que nous avons bien avancé
voilà il est il est atteint il y a
encore bien sûr beaucoup de choses à
faire pour moi avoir de nouveau une
confiance pleine et entière mais
aujourd'hui plus de 500 millions d'euros
donc
la page est tournée maintenant il faut
il faut rebâtir justement cette
confiance autour de projets concrets et
c'est ça l'important et je pense que ces
projets ils sont sur la table nous avons
beaucoup à faire notamment dans le
domaine des énergies de renouvelables
des mobilités de la transport nous avons
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises qui
sont aujourd'hui implantés je pense
notamment à Transdev Alstom je pense
aussi dans le domaine des énergies
renouvelables à newen qui est un acteur
majeur du marché très bien dans le
solaire qui est une entreprise française
qu'on connaît finalement peu en France
et dans le monde et qui pourtant là-bas
est un acteur majeur oui et puis ensuite
le deuxième objectif si vous voulez
au-delà de l'Australie c'était de
réaffirmer la place de la France dans ce
qu'on appelle l'Indo Pacifique et la
France est un acteur majeur de
l'Indo-Pacifique beaucoup de gens voient
la France via l'Hexagone en Europe mais
en réalité la France c'est un acteur de
l'Indopacifique pourquoi parce que nous
avons 1,6 millions de Français qui
vivent sur des territoires français en
adopacifique à la Réunion à Mayotte à
walee Futuna en Nouvelle-Calédonie en
Polynésie française notamment et donc
voilà c'est c'est français sont des
acteurs de l'Indo Pacifique nous avons
également les trois quarts de notre zone
économique exclusive cette zone maritime
vous savez que la France que la deuxième
du monde la deuxième zone maritime du
monde voilà les trois de cette zone
maritime elles sont en de Pacifique
c'est très important il y a en ce moment
une négociation sur un traité de
libre-échange avec l'Union européenne
vous avez à défendre des intérêts et
là-dessus c'est pas très très clair
notamment en ce qui concerne
l'agriculture alors je pense que au
niveau de l'agriculture si vous voulez
il faut toujours être très prudent parce
que quand on regarde les traités on se
dit toujours ouh là là les Français on
va payer cher ces accords de
libre-échange et quand on regarde le
CETA quand on regarde notamment la
Nouvelle-Zélande on se rend compte que
ce sont des traités favorables qui sont
favorables
dans les faits
c'est très clairement le cas pour
l'Australie
le traité va s'écrire il se négocie avec
l'Union européenne et ce que nous
souhaitons et ça c'est une vraie
révolution maintenant que nous mettons
dans les traités de commerce c'est faire
en sorte
que c'est traités ne soient pas
simplement du libre-échange parfois un
peu naïf mais soit du libre-échange
responsable c'est à dire que nous
mettons dans les traités de commerce des
clauses qui disent qu'on doit s'engager
mutuellement au respect des accords de
Paris pour le climat pour protéger la
planète la biodiversité pour faire en
sorte aussi que on respecte les normes
sociales le droit du travail les
engagements de l'Organisation
internationale du Travail et puis
derrière on met aussi en ce moment
est-ce qu'on a encore besoin d'un traité
de libre-échange de bateaux
supplémentaires sur les mers pour nous
amener des produits qui sont à 12000 km
mais est-ce que vraiment c'est l'urgence
mais vous savez que les produits que
nous envoyons là-bas c'est aussi la
capacité à ramener des produits chez
nous et par exemple en Australie il
produisent des terres rares du nickel du
cobalt du lithium dont nous allons avoir
besoin nous pour les fameuses batteries
pour faire transition énergétique parce
que sinon on peut construire toutes les
voitures électriques du monde qu'on veut
si on n'a pas les matières premières
pour mettre les batteries et bien pas
besoin
il y a toujours besoin d'un traité de
Limoges j'ai le traité de libre-échange
c'est quoi le traité libre échange c'est
fixer les règles c'est de dire si vous
importez chez nous voilà les conditions
dans lesquelles vous rentrez si on
exporte chez eux voilà les conditions
dans lesquelles on le fait un traité de
libre-échange c'est pas une fenêtre
ouverte à tous les vents de la
mondialisation c'est un cadre alors la
France combien de divisions économiques
en Indo-Pacifique vous avez dit qu'on
était un million 600000 citoyens là-bas
mais c'est quoi les divisions
économiques des Français de l'étranger
dans les différents pays les États-Unis
ils ont le quad avec l'un de le Japon et
l'Australie ils ont aussi oculus le lien
militaire avec l'Australie et le
Royaume-Uni Biden a lancé toute une
stratégie de cadre économique sur
l'adopacifique c'est quoi nos armes
économiques alors nos armes nos
premières armes économiques se sont qui
sont massivement implantés je vous ai
donné l'exemple de Transdev ou d'Alstom
ou de newen en Australie j'aurais pu
également vous donner l'exemple de CMA
CGM 35% oui le transporteur Singapour
c'est quand même le deuxième port au
monde et il est opéré en grande partie
avec CMA CGM donc cette force économique
ou pas ça représente quoi en chiffre
d'affaires en pourcentage de notre PIB
c'est quoi c'est compliqué à faire en
pourcentage du Pipe parce que c'est
comparé des choux avec des carottes mais
si vous voulez je vous donne un exemple
sur l'Australie l'Australie la présence
des entreprises françaises en Australie
c'est 60 000 emplois d'accord c'est 60
000 ans et donc ce sont des revenus
aussi qui reviennent en France derrière
parce que les profits que font ces
entreprises sont ensuite rapatriés il y
a dans les groupes en France donc
parfois on a une balance commerciale qui
est déficitaire mais on a une balance
des revenus logiciel et donc sédentaire
se défendent bien là-bas nous
entreprises se défendent bien là-bas
elles peuvent encore mieux faire je
pense que nous avons un challenge pour
porter les petites et moyennes
entreprises à l'exportation dans ces
pays c'est aussi par les grandes
normalement et même pas seulement si
vous voulez pas seulement une entreprise
qui fait des confitures
petites une trentaine de salariés et qui
va exporter dans tous les pays du monde
elle va faire quoi elle va créer de
l'emploi ici en France elle va créer de
la richesse c'est-à-dire des impôts qui
vont permettre de financer notre modèle
de service public qui va permettre de
financer notre protection sociale donc
vous voyez que au final le commerce
c'est bon pour
l'économie française c'est bon pour
l'emploi c'est bon pour notre système
national vous savez il y a quand même un
phénomène historique les pays les plus
ouverts au monde ceux qui ont été des
grandes puissances commerciales ont été
aussi les pays les plus prospères les
cité les plus prospères de Venise à
Bruges
bien avant oui mais pas toujours ce que
je voulais essayer et les pays les plus
fermés ont généralement été les plus
pauvres regardez aujourd'hui la Corée du
Nord pas la Chine millénaires la Chine a
été fermée elle n'a été ouverte que sous
la pression des guerres de l'opium et
elle n'a pas été pauvre elle ne voulait
justement pas des produits des
occidentaux
au même rythme le Japon aussi était
fermé sous l'ère des Tokugawa mais il ne
sait pas lire un coup de canon et il
s'est développé et je pense que ceux qui
connaissent un peu l'histoire verront
que le Japon de l'air avant maiji et le
Japon de l'arméegie ce n'est pas tout à
fait la même chose en termes de prospect
est-ce que les entreprises que vous avez
visitées ont besoin de l'état où est-ce
qu'elles n'ont pas besoin elles vont se
développer elle-même alors beaucoup de
grandes entreprises peuvent le faire les
petites c'est plus compliqué donc on a
tout un dispositif notamment avec
business France avec BPI France etc pour
accompagner ces entreprises à
l'exportation à l'internationalisation
et puis le rôle de l'État c'est aussi
d'entretenir des relations humaines
quand je me déplace en Australie quand
je me déplace à Singapour ou en
Indonésie c'est aussi pour rencontrer
des ministres des chefs d'entreprise des
responsables locaux c'est pour tisser
des liens humains et vous savez on me
parle toujours de la question de est-ce
que vous moissonnez est-ce que vous
récoltez des contrats bon pour récolter
il faut d'abord semer on sème les
graines on les arrose et ensuite on peut
récolter on dira que les graines sont
semées en Australie qu'il y a un gros
travail sur le reste Indonésie Singapour
etc ou pas les graines sont aussi semées
à Singapour et vous verrez très
prochainement des résultats qui je pense
seront très intéressants pour notre pays
indon aussi et Indonésie également
Indonésie c'est un énorme marché vous
savez l'Indonésie c'est le quatrième
pays le plus peuplé au monde je souhaite
qu'il y ait davantage d'entreprises
françaises qui s'intéressent à ces
marchés je pense notamment dans le
domaine de l'énergie on a encore
beaucoup à construire dernière question
est-ce qu'on peut être en conquête
économique sans le support de la défense
d'humilité comme le font parfaitement
bien les États-Unis à travers les
différentes oui ce que il faut réarmer
la France aussi dans cette région alors
si vous voulez le les contrats
militaires c'est une chose nous avons
une stratégie Indo-Pacifique qui
comporte aussi évidemment un volet
défense et la défense de nos intérêts
français dans cette zone du monde mais
aussi la défense de la paix qui a et de
nos valeurs du multilatéralisme de la
liberté de naviguer qui sont des valeurs
fortes en plus des droits de l'homme de
la démocratie ou de l'État de droit mais
nous avons aussi une diplomatie
économique qui elle ne dépend pas du
militaire on ne fait pas que vendre des
rafales des sous-marins
dans ce dans ces hélicoptères dans ces
régions du monde on investit aussi pour
l'environnement pour le développement
durable pour les énergies renouvelables
pour la protection de la biodiversité et
ça c'est aussi l'avenir de notre planète
des générations futures qu'on est en
train d'inventer merci Monsieur le
Ministre Olivier belge pour vos réponses
l'entretien de l'intelligence économique
est terminée évidemment vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission sur France
24.com sur nos réseaux sociaux et sur
nos podcasts au revoir
[Musique]